[Music]
what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
commentate about honest trailers
hopefully one of those who just watched
it's called a wrinkle in time and if you
stick around here we're gonna give you
our deep thoughts behind the film by
writing the trailer and if you stick
around to the end a lot of deleted
scenes this time actually yeah almost as
long as the trailer itself it's a short
one but you know what I banged out a
rough draft I left for Spain and that's
what you get some weeks but you guys
stepped up to the plate tell me what is
your main takeaways from this film well
I was one of the only one of the three
of us or really most people in the
country who saw this in the theater and
yeah I kind of pushed for us to do this
because I like doing honest trailers of
super weird movies and this movie is
effing weird man yep this is one of the
weirdest movies that I've seen in a long
time and I just wanted us to do a movie
about leaf Reese Reese with a spoon and
giant leaf for this these kind of movies
only come along once once ever once in a
generation I
okay well Joe you you tell us so I went
into this movie knowing how much
everyone hated it and how everyone was
like oh my god it's like this insane
crazy bizarre garbage fire and so I
watched it and I also read the book
yeah thanks it's fine
but it's like the books just as insane
like I don't know I don't know how you
make this movie I really don't I think
it's it's the king of you know Dana's
famous for saying you can just not make
a movie and I think wrinkle in time is
like the poster child for but people
have heard of it so you have to make it
a movie a recognizable thing yeah yeah I
think that this was a really good movie
if you have not been tainted by certain
cynicism in your life yet and you
haven't heard all the inspirational
quotes and posts on your Facebook feed I
think this is a good movie for as
in the trailer ten-year-old girls and
people who are currently high I do think
that was like this will be one of those
movies that is not like Fantasia
definitely not like that exalted but
definitely something that's like this
will be a forgotten like whoa did you
see that because that is not slipping
like people will mute this movie put on
Dark Side of the Moon watch this for
years to come yeah I didn't hate it it's
not for me it's dated it's just weird
like the cadence is weird yeah it's got
a weird like you know movies have a
rhythm and this movie just has a never
quite catches a rhythm it just kind of
goes from thing to thing and it's very
non like it's very just kind of in its
own world and it doesn't really invite
you into it it's just like you're gonna
watch this and you're gonna like it yeah
very kind of like it's the interesting
sorry because it was the book because
the book was like and this weird lady
just showed up in your house and she's
bumbling along you made her sandwich and
then she pulled your mom in close and
said there's such a thing as a tesseract
and then she leaves and then you're like
who was that mom and why does my little
brother not seem worried about her and
then all written in the second person
okay but it's just like one thing after
another hey you know your brother's like
so basically like a weird mutant god kid
right and then you know right and I
weird idea after idea after idea and
yeah at no point does it like take a
breath it feels like a it's a scavenger
hunt and you're going from like point A
to B to C to D to e to F but then to get
from each point they just make up new
rules or just say new things like yeah
now you know you're tired from testing
so you need to meet Zach Galifianakis
okay yeah it's it's an end then movie
watch Jurassic world thing it's like
there's movies that are because of
movies like because this happened and
now this is gonna happen and this is and
then movies happens this is that and
then there's a thing and then we went to
this thing with his flowers and then we
went to a cave Zach Galifianakis and
then we went to neighborhood with a
bunch of people bouncing balls and then
we went to this white room and then we
went it's just like okay I get and then
and then and then yours at the end what
the hell it feels like a Kincaid
describing the dream they had yeah yeah
putting it yeah so it was weird it was
unique but largely unenjoyable except
out of sheer appreciation for how
strange it was yeah it's yeah and even
just I I wonder why because I think she
I mean like if you look at like Selma
and 13th like Ava Duvernay such an
amazing director and even then it's just
like I wonder what why you would look at
her work and then this movie be like
this is the perfect marriage of these
two because I mean her calls she had a
great I mean it is a it is a very
distinct division and they committed to
a pulley and you can say that but it's
just it's so weird I didn't I would
never have guessed that she would be
attracted to a project like this given
yeah her other work you know I can I can
see the the attraction of being able to
tell a story for like 11 year old kids
that need some self-confidence you need
to realize that they're beautiful and
they're tough and that they can you know
roll up their sleeves and and get into
the world but this is a this is that
story with a whole lot of baggage
attached to it a whole lot of really
weird weird trippy baggage and the best
stuff is when it gets that story about
like you know finding yourself and why
people are mean to each other and that's
that's the best parts of it one touch at
the end exactly and this guy got passed
over for promotion and yeah but it's
everything else it's just like wow it's
crazy yeah crazy I don't know yeah well
let's uh trip the light fantastic and
watch Arnaz trailer for wrinkle in time
on
from Disney the studio that will soon
make every one of the movies you see
comes a movie made for everyone from
ten-year-old girls to people high on
shrooms to actually that's pretty much
it this one is really neat yeah that's
that shot of like the when the first
start like traveling and the the tree is
kind of vibrating oh yeah that's exactly
how it feels right there like a little
wobbly and like nature's kind of
breathing and a little fractally that
was I was like okay I see see what's
what visual effects who provides testers
yeah okay anyways I'd point that out
their father and learning to believe in
herself while at the same time director
Ava Duvernay pours LSD directly into
both your eyeballs in a bonkers mix have
grounded straightforward storytelling
and Reese Witherspoon transforming into
a giant flying leap oh c'mon this is the
part of the movie I was like what is
going in the book and then the earlier
movie that will mention later from 2004
she transforms into like a big Pegasus
with a Reese Witherspoon head I would
have Corey would have been a Reese
Witherspoon head had she played her yeah
do you think Reese has been got to
design what she was just like you know
what I've always wanted to do with this
story get rid of that Pegasus thing and
put in this leaf yeah Pokemon Jerry you
into like like I can't even describe
that thing it's like a hang-glider
also she's like that remember her old
star I don't know she's like a wet she's
a three million year old star well they
all are right thank know like the old
wizard that you can't actually see oh
she's like a star or she played the
movie do what
yes that was interesting I do remember
that is that Oprah's character is
something that you can never see yeah
which he'll know you don't bring over it
for a voice cameo the biggest thing
literally in the movie goku hair that's
the ultimate level of super saiyan
it's just oprah meet meg a girl who gets
bullied about as much as meg from their
rough on me shut up shut up Meg winner
did tell us she spends the whole first
half of the movie getting relentlessly
bullied and the whole second half of the
movie getting relentlessly complimented
yeah three the three fairies the the boy
her brother dad like everyone's like
you're the most beautiful woman in the
world you're so smart you're the best
and like it's just interesting how they
like boom like switch on a dime I I
guess maybe I was I don't know I I mean
I I had my run-ins with bullies in
middle school and usually it's over
appearance or it's over something that
you're into or it's over you know maybe
your socioeconomic status but like the
bullying in this movie like do people
really guess she was like being bullied
because her dad was just like is our
yeah I guess I just didn't realize how
cruel bullies could be like you're being
picked on because your father police
appeared well mostly because like
because they were orphans I don't know
that I that did strike me as like very
cruel that's the kool-aid for having it
her her dad disappeared and I guess like
he was a crackpot you know it was like
sure he had these bizarre theories so
they bullied her for that and then but
how so bullied her for what was it
having a weird brother having a weird
brother which again is that a thing I
mean is that bullies are just way more
vicious than ish asymmetry
but yeah yeah those are really personal
bullies oh and for having the cute boy
over at her house there she's like you
gotta get out of here like they're gonna
rehearse it was for his sake yeah that's
right dad with her yeah
because her father disappeared if you
know you can never get over that
principle with that school bad principal
really like sits her down and he's like
hey what are you gonna go over the fact
of your dad's probably dead yeah
what a weird kid weird kid as a stupid
missing father like what the hell who
are you people
no wonder your children are terrible
bullies you're terrible people I guess
she didn't even need extreme
complementing the offset oh they were
just like really giving it to her both
very sad no just to say something nice
about that movie she's a good little
actor she's right she was very good I
like to liked her did not like the
brother and they had him say crazy Harry
a lot of the lows
he was very precocious but that was his
only speed was precocious did I explain
and God bless it young why he's like is
he an alien
do you just never find out why's the
first half of the book is just a lot of
people like including his mom be like I
thought you hae ragequit yeah this giant
slam it's just a lot of people being
like I mean we all know that he's not
quite like the rest of us you know in
like a wink wink nod nod he's like a
crazy telepath weirdo probably but it's
only like a wink and a nod yeah and also
just peer like Dan said like pure except
it's like this is this is the story like
deal with it like this is the thing
JT you okay you okay back there you good
and crosses the universe with the power
of love
that's the frequency the reverse mark
situation and a cute boy who just kind
of wanders in what are you doing here I
don't know together your dad on the set
of brakes hotline bling video you're a
negativity that feeds on children known
as it no the other embodiment of fear
as hit that's the one one thing that I
noticed but I just never mentioned or
forgot to mention was that the kid he
has like more layers he dresses in more
he has like a big huge like like a like
a varsity jacket that he takes off and
then he has like a t-shirt and then
underneath that t-shirt he has another
full t-shirt it's like I've never seen
anybody dress a brother the kid the kid
the dude did the kid he has like he just
isn't like five full layers of clothing
it's very bizarre like I like to maybe I
get but like a full t-shirt under is
that a trend and I just never caught on
to full t-shirts underneath a jacket
well if you were in middle school his
body was going through certain changes I
feel like you know you perspire more
than you usually do and you need a
burner t-shirt I don't know I just I
just never cuz like I rock like a
t-shirt and then I wear like an
undershirt like like a tank top sure but
I don't know maybe I'm just not up with
the with the latest trends that it's
like jacket over t-shirt over another
completely different t-shirt now instead
of a hat with the price tag still
attached it's just three different three
different hats I don't know it was a
weird detail that I obviously never
mention because it's just too strange
very strange Marty McFly continually
shed layers in the past but every layer
was just another touch of the best
future jacket kid ready for more Eila
stars dressed like J pop idols than an
anime themed Met Gala featuring the
larger-than-life Weiss age known as
Oprah as a more grounded 100 foot tall
version of herself weird Reese with
spoon as your favorite we're dads
warriors who serve the good and light of
the universe and Mindy Kaling has that
copy of Bartlett's familiar quotations
you leave near the toilet tomorrow but
that was too personal to my bathroom but
Miranda American that feels the but when
it feels the ground Buddha Nepali
American who was who I guess would have
been the Chris checker equivalent in 70s
in the 70s and 70s like Richard
Roundtree no no Richard Pryor quotes
yeah not the PG movie mm-hmm that guy
had sex with Marlon Brando so weird not
like you know that having sex part but
the fact that they yes yes - out of all
the people in the world have found each
other to have sex with each other what
is that a Superman convention at a
super-wide yeah they're both oh yeah
jor-el and computer guy Gus I want
Hackman got in their show I want to give
that Cliff Lee Jones interview these
visuals and just see what happened yeah
you should you should read that so that
real Disney Joker two objects which
enchanted critics and made over a
billion dollars at the but wait what
it wasn't a critical success I'm
underwhelmed and it was a box-office
disappointment and this isn't the first
time they screwed up wrinkle in time
yeah that's impossible I mean that just
doesn't happen to Disney is this a dream
no seriously is this a dream am I
dreaming right now man cuz I had a
couple of edibles before seeing the
movie and I'm just kind of waiting for
the second way to kick it Oh
good region story the following lines
from the movie they've worked better as
motivational Instagram posts read and
imagine McConaughey voice pause so now i
IE mailed you to be fair I did email you
and said what if he read these in a
Matthew McConaughey voice cuz and I did
not respond you did not respond vacation
check that is approval but I did the oh
and by the way props to John who on the
voice record session was like you know
they've made this already right I was
like what well and they sent me the 2004
trailer I know we hide the movie so that
was a John catch but I was just we
hadn't had a definitive answer from
fearless so I was like can you go ahead
and do this Matthew McConaughey thing -
they were just funny it's funnier I
don't know why but it is just funny it's
just I don't know why I was I was
reading the script and I just in my head
started reading them in a Matthew
McConaughey like a Lincoln commercial
like a Lincoln or Carl's jr. ad and it's
just like John could do Matthew
McConaughey I was like what if we to me
the lotteries in it ii edibles kicked in
and now he can only maybe that's what it
was I don't know I all right well let's
hear it so yeah without love is like a
tree blossom throw lines from the movie
the wound is the place for the light
enters you what if we are not just in
the universe in order to be great it
isn't enough just to be right love looks
not with the eyes but with a mind
I wanted to shake hands with universe I
should have been holding yours all right
to you I give the gift of your faults my
gift
it's my command note to self don't
invite Reese Witherspoon and Oprah to
your Secret Santa their gift suck
where's the car
ya know it's like the weird of the car
yeah first ladies like you think it's
like the Lord of the Rings scene where
it's like here's the glasses brakes
here's the rope and the bread she's like
I fall I give you here boss well we
didn't get into it but resource
regressive she hates her the whole movie
yes she's another one of the bullies
like kind of piling on like really her
yeah but yeah she gave her fault so it's
important to view your faults Thanks
I know self my faults every day well
short trailer but lots of cut stuff so
let's see what didn't make it
strap it as director Ava Duvernay proves
that faithfully adapting a classic
children's book isn't always a good
thing
as she accurately brings to life it's
crazy concepts insane visuals and absurd
dialogue wild nights in my glory happy
seats I was chosen for my great
verbalizing and materializing skills to
explore themes like family love
embracing your flaws and the reality
that some crazy children's books can
just you know stay books I can't tell
what they're saying
I can't they speak color mm-hmm of
course they do
as a weird sauce yeah yeah just too much
reading a lot of reading and which words
yeah you know yes any time we judge
direct comparisons to books that always
brings out an element of the crowd that
knows more than we some wrinkle stands
gonna be like yeah yeah we gotta we just
stick to the movies yeah I feel like
that happened with the Hunger Games our
defense was that we were just basically
just talking about the movie so I
figured bring the books in and we just
opened up a whole new
Maes your honor I think was actually the
most the first major honour that we got
from the books like wow if you wrote the
book it was very like well we didn't
obviously so sorry sorry if we
misrepresented the Scotch but I know
you'll never make corn scourge sense I
enjoyed me in the score just kind of
wonders it what are you doing here
I don't know you know exactly why you
showed up dude he creeped me out I gotta
be honest yeah it's good red child
everything done totally down stalker
eyes oh that was the old voice oh yeah
John did add two different now
he did yeah originally we recorded
through a mutual misunderstanding slash
rushing to see he recorded the trailer
originally and a different Disney voice
that was separate from this Disney voice
yes is good but like it felt too
different yeah it was just gonna be ever
like nothing but people going like you
got a voice guy and yeah yeah just we
went through it with Harry Potter where
we did something accurate and people
were like bring back the old boy it's
the same guy the credits do more than
one so yeah we didn't include it with
the run but the the the climax of the
staring is uh he leaves the house and
closes the door and he looks at it
through the window for a minute and
walks away into the next well no I
didn't know there's a three windows
stare persuade to doing did we miss a
chance to do a stairs montage power of
stairs I don't know does anyone still
remember that I don't think anybody
would be more confusing at this boy
residues
no shield agents of shield x3 or the
x-men trilogy yeah and of course
Twilight yeah yeah Star Trek oh really
yeah well flares it would have been
weird if Matthew McConaughey had
suddenly been like an stairs
do you ever when we did stairs let us
know in the comments below or would it
just be confusing yeah just be confusing
then all the questions would just be
what's the music track which we've also
answered several times which I also
still can't remember so people have just
stopped asking I used to know it offhand
because that was the only question
anyone ever asked us was there music
yeah look it up alright do you have
anything else it's only down stalker
eyes starring the following lines from
the movie they've worked better as
motivational Instagram posts written
occur just the birth of the universe do
you I give the gift of your thoughts
Electric kool-aid acid fast oh that's
that The Imaginarium of dr. dubrow nay
that's the other voice that was thinking
it's a good thing these strange ladies
that Charles Wallace invited into his
house we're mystical beings who wanted
to whisk him away on an adventure
because nine times out of ten if you run
into a crazy lady's old run-down house
there's gonna be a murder
so it's mrs. witch whatsit and who I
wonder who they're married to my guess
is the rock T Mac and Ryan so I thought
it was when they said the missus I heard
like the plural of Miss OH
oh it's the missus and then wouldn't
they call them individually like mrs.
who or did they call it missus oh then I
miss that I know it's probably better
this is this is probably whatever oh
this feels very there is no Doctor Who
is there mister what's it is that the
mister what's it I don't know
there's a mr. fix it fix it Felix man is
there a dr. pepper it could be a woman
sexist sexist this movie could've been a
lot worse
real that book is just goes like because
after the the street with the with the
basketball and then they do their real
quick beach thing and then they she puts
on the glasses and finds her dad and
they can then fights a tentacle thing
and gets out there's so much more book
they let go into a whole city of
basketball thing like it just keeps on
going I always I thought I had read this
before and I kept waiting for the
doldrums to show up and I realized that
something about the Phantom Tollbooth ah
yeah which I was excited for I remember
that's a cool anime movie I'm sure
doesn't he'll make it sir
it's coming it's coming in yeah any
other what's your childhood classic that
you're waiting for or slash has been
made and ruined mmm oh man all of mine
have been roasted yeah most of them have
been made I think I hope they never
unearthed an American tale like it's
perfect the way it is yeah don't need to
redo it but you know they will egg
someday I grew up with a book series
called the dark is rising which I loved
which they made into a terrible movie
called like The Seeker the dark is
rising like 15 oh yeah yeah that was
horrible
and then Golden Compass which was awful
and didn't have an ending okay did they
make a bad encyclopedia brown movie I
think they did cuz I read those
encyclopedia Browns Henry Huggins I
don't think they ever made into a movie
I read those books Orson Scott Card
talking ruined Ender's Game for me but
then the movie are we due for a Ramona
reboot probably probably did they ever
do the beverly cleary purse Oh Ramona
already think so probably how about you
guys have read those met Christopher
books about kids who were magically
really good at sports know what nutty
can't-miss is like Avengers but well
they never met but it was like different
kids who through different magical
happenstance like man could only hit
homeruns
it's fine my mom just made me read dear
mr. Henshaw Oh
pressing well we're giving so many
studios so many ideas Hardy Boys comedy
oh man yeah the whole hearty verse
Nate's he drew Hardy Boys babysitter's
clapping oh yeah that's you know that's
coming
you've gotta be the the United kids that
solve mysteries verse the Boxcar
Children can show up oh yes yeah what
about the mr. and mrs. books get they
ever get those we're talking baby stuff
now oh yeah the tape oh yeah it's coming
yeah there you go well you've enjoyed us
talking about a wrinkle in time we'll be
talking about a movie for a little bit
and something else for a lot longer next
week when we discuss what are we doing
next week Oh something really good you
could probably find another word for
really good that would describe it
mm-hmm yeah yep I got my weeks mixed up
and I was like you're being very
sarcastic yeah no you're right this is
very good very good
yes I hope you think this has been at
least average and we'll catch you next
week here on honest trailer commentaries
you
[Music]